today we're going to look at a result
called the russell paradox it's part of
our general effort
to really understand what undecidability
is all about because in the end we're
going to move forward in time and we're
going to
redo and re-examine alan turing's
halting problem paradox for his turing
machines
and to understand it completely and
totally you really do need to understand
a lot about the nature of paradoxes and
the nature of undecidability something
that's undecidable in one given small
set of propositions may become decidable
in a bigger system
the german mathematician david hilbert
occupied a similar place in the
mathematical firmament to carl friedrich
gauss his predecessor hilbert
was really upset by the whole notion
that things might be undecidable
he'd already encountered the parallel
lines problem that we've
done in another video he could see that
this could lead to real trouble but i
think he was
very pleased indeed when two
mathematical philosophers here in the uk
decided that they would have a go
at
axiomatizing
simple arithmetic essentially the
natural numbers zero and the positive
integers bertrand russell very famous
alfred north whitehead another
famous mathematician older than russell
he was russell's research supervisor
between them they decided they would
have a go at this they were well
equipped because
russell
in his twenties had made his name as a
very famous mathematical logician
and in his investigations about how to
axiomatize arithmetic he came across the
work of another mathematical logician
called gottlob fraga gottlob frager said
if you're going to axiomatize arithmetic
on simple numbers a really good way to
do it is to
talk about
sets
now this isn't intuitively obvious to us
mere mortals but they were obsessed
about the fact that
what is two two is a thing you draw like
that like the neck of a swan in western
europe as bertrand used to love saying
what is the twoness of two
and they decided
effectively
what two represented was a union of the
set of all sets that had two members in
them like black and white or yin and
yang or male and female
that was the essence of tunas so they
got into this business of talking about
the cardinality of sets in other words
the number of members in a set fragra
did a huge amount of work on this on
axiomatizing everything in terms of set
theory although he actually called it
class theory in those days but that's an
old-fashioned term now it really was set
theory
so in the early years of the 20th
century fraga sent a copy of his book on
axiomatic set theory to bertrand russell
just to look at
dear russell i'm sure you'll enjoy this
sort of thing
and russell had already been doing lots
of
preparatory work if you like trying to
think out well if you try to axiomatize
using this
fragra idea of sets will you get into
trouble
and yes russell had spotted you would
get into trouble
he got the book looked through it and
wrote this famous letter to fraga
apparently this is not apocryphal you
really did write it have you considered
the set of all sets that are not members
of themselves
is that set a member of itself or not
now to you and i would just say what but
to fraga is oh no
oh no
this really ruins everything
so why did it ruin everything well it
ruined everything because it leads to a
paradox and of course this has now
become so famous it's called the russell
paradox it's later years russell used to
say
that is a little difficult let's tackle
it from the point of view of the barber
paradox in a certain village
there is a local law
that all males must be clean-shaven
the village barber will shave all those
who do not shave themselves
question who shaves the barber well we
have this lovely picture that if you're
an aristocrat you can afford your own
grazer but if you couldn't shave
yourself you weren't allowed to grow a
beard you won't see the village barber
he would shave you
but where does the paradox come it's
right at the end it says all right who
shaves the barber and when you think
about it this is dreadful the barber
shaves only those who do not shave
themselves the barber doesn't take out
his cutthroat razor just wanders around
thinks oh dear i'm growing a beard the
local laws don't allow this you're
completely caught if he does shave
himself then he shouldn't have done it
and if he
doesn't shave himself then you should
have done it because all men must be
clean-shaven actually in modern parlance
the question who shaves the barber is
undecidable the system of propositions
about being clean-shaven in that village
is not strong enough to decide who
shaves the barber so what do we do when
we hit a paradox now
we try and think outside the box lateral
thinking
this one is easy
thinking outside the box how can we
resolve this paradox well at least two
ways the barber is a woman
let's presume that women don't shave
themselves don't need to shave
themselves there's no need to ask the
question of who shaves the barber
because the barber doesn't need to shave
herself
another way out of the problem is to
expand the series of local laws and make
a special amendment and say the barber
himself is required to be bearded there
will be no attempt made by the barber to
shave himself therefore there is no
paradox so that's two possible ways of
thinking outside the box and resolving
the paradox so
nice result it turned out in actual fact
um
coming forward to girdle and turing's
work that an awful lot of undecidability
or paradoxical situations can in the end
be structurally
simplified down to the barber paradox
russell and whitehead were very happy to
tell fraga that his system wasn't robust
enough to do what they wanted but they'd
seen this coming
fraga was massively upset tried to get
around the problem by saying my set
system works fine so long as you exclude
phrases like the set of all sets
well um yes there was a workaround i
think wrestling whitehead thought it was
inelegant and didn't like it they then
tried for their principia which they
published in i think 1910 or three
volumes of it to get around it with a
theory of types
basically saying what sort of things you
could make sets of and whatnot it
convinced them
but an awful lot of people still
remained unconvinced even by that it's
basically saying there is a nasty
situation here this is a more
sophisticated work around perhaps but
it's still a workaround
meanwhile in the background david
hilberts had been working on his own
system of mathematical logic
similar in some ways perhaps to what
russell and whitehead were doing
the nasty shock in for all of them
russell whitehead and hilbert
was in 1931 a young mathematical
logician on the rise came along curt
godel and just blew a hole in all
of their hypotheses really sunk them
below the water line what girdle managed
to prove in 1931
was that any system of mathematically
logical propositions that was powerful
enough to enable one thing to be derived
from another
was inevitably going to be able to
generate new results and new theorems
which were true
but not provable within the set of
axioms that you'd already got in other
words what he was saying was
parallel lines being true but not
provable no it's not a one-off accident
these things happen and he was saying to
russell whitehead and hilbert i don't
care how much you decorate up your
systems i am telling you i've got an
incompleteness theorem
any set of propositions will necessarily
be incomplete i can prove it to you
there will be things in your
propositions that are true but are not
provable from your propositions
so bertrand russell i remember in one of
his interviews was asked well what about
girdle because i understand professors
there's serious problems with what
you've done
but wrestle memorably said i have never
met a girdle but i don't think he would
be a nice person
um hilbert
was much angrier hilbert was reported to
be angry by girdle's result in 1931
opinions differ as to why he was angry
some say well he was angry because he
didn't want mathematics to be like this
he wanted it to be decidable absolutely
some say no hilbert was angry because he
was ultra smart he was messing about
with this stuff he should have spotted
this for himself
we'd like to thank little bits for uh
sponsoring this computer video i've got
one of their kits here if you've never
seen little bits or heard of them check
their website out littlebits.com they're
an excellent modular electronics kit for
prototyping or learning about
electronics i've been using this kit and
playing with it with my five-year-old
son and he got to grips with it really
really quickly we have made an
electronic tickling machine and a waving
hand that waves when you say boo
they've got a magnetic system which
means that you just click the modules
together and they can't go together the
wrong way because the magnets are set up
in that way so you just click it
together it's color coded so it's pretty
straightforward orange bits are
connectors green bits do things blue is
power really really clever little system
check their website out have a look at
them they're littlebits.com and if you
use the coupon computer file you can get
twenty dollars off your first purchase
they even come with a nine volt battery
so in true children's television style
here's one i made earlier